別看他今天穿的白白凈凈了我們給你講點髒事吧。2023年8月15日晚超過400名的新加坡警察同時突擊搜查了9個新加坡頂級高檔住宅這是他們經過了數年暗中偵查之後的大規模收網行動其中一名驚慌的嫌疑人還在嘗試逃竄從家裡二樓的陽臺上直接跳下來手腕腳腕全都扭傷了一瘸一拐躲到下水道里最後還是被找到了
當晚總共抓捕了10名嫌疑人豪車、藝術品、加密貨幣資產名錶、奢侈品包包、現金等等總計價值超過10億美元的資產被查封其實這次的嫌犯總共有27人而這個收網只抓捕到了10個人剩下17人還不在新加坡境內至今在逃後來易會總發現這個合計的贓款超過了30億美元
這筆巨額的贓款主要來源於一個基於東南亞的非法線上賭博平臺也有的來自一些非法借貸業務包括線上詐騙等等最終還是在新加坡洗錢的時候露出了麻將這個就是震驚世界的新加坡洗錢案也是毫無疑問新加坡有史以來規模最大的洗錢案
這個案子具體怎麼回事這錢怎麼洗的我們一會兒再聊今天我們的視頻可遠不止這麼簡單我想去展開聊一個我個人覺得更有意思也是更宏大得多的一個主題根據聯合國一個非常粗略的估算全球每年洗錢的規模會達到GDP的2%到5%注意一下是全球GDP的2%到5%大概是超過2萬億美元的規模
就我們身邊可能各行各業看起來非常多稀鬆平常的經濟活動什麼藝術品奢侈品房產的買賣企業的投融資哪怕就是普通的存錢轉賬都有可能暗藏著洗錢的購買我跟你說為了這期視頻我可是看了上百種洗錢的方法上百個經典的案例就一開始我還覺得這怎麼亂七八糟的有點摸不著頭緒但慢慢我就發現理解了通了
那咱今天就廢話少說，帶大家一口氣瞭解一下洗錢是怎麼回事。注意啊，咱先強調一下，洗錢它肯定是違法的。不能洗錢。不能洗錢。不能洗錢。咱這視頻就是科普，主要是讓大家更好的瞭解一下洗錢，也可以更好的防範洗錢，更好的瞭解一下這個世界的運行的規則。為了不讓它成為一個教學視頻，很多一些具體的操作手法我就不講那麼詳細了，咱點到為止。
洗錢那簡單來說就是把罪犯所得到的髒款經過一系列的手法把它合法化讓它光明正大就可以花也就是把髒錢給洗乾淨的過程那可能有人上來就要問了髒款你直接花就完了唄幹嘛要洗它呢你要是騙來三五千塊錢甚至三五萬塊錢你確實可以直接花這沒什麼大問題那你要是有三五百萬三五千萬甚至三五個億的髒款呢
這有點像什麼？就比如說有一個小學生，咱就叫他小壞蛋。有一天他在學校裡無意之間撿到了一個錢包一百塊，一萬塊錢。這在小學生的世界裡可算是一筆鉅款。小壞蛋他就萌生了一個邪惡的想法，他想把這筆鉅款給拒得一己有。
但你想他如果直接拿著這個錢去買一個新款的iPhone手機回到家他的監管機構就是他媽一旦問起來那多不好交代啊所以理想情況是什麼這個小壞蛋他想光明正大的在他媽眼皮底下把這個錢給花掉他就需要非常合理化的向他媽解釋這個錢是哪來的他就需要洗錢了怎麼樣能不能感同身受一點啊就當你這個髒款變的數額巨大的時候洗錢就非常有必要了
你想作為這個拿到巨額贓款的罪犯他需要解決兩個問題一個就是他需要盡量讓這個錢變得難以追蹤把你的腳印給擦乾淨你想被騙的人他肯定會報警所以你就得想辦法讓這個警察很難順著這筆錢順藤摸瓜的查到你的賬上這是第一第二就是要讓這筆錢變得非常合理因為你想就算警察可能沒辦法順藤摸瓜查到你的賬上但是你一個普普通通小職員一個月兩三千塊錢工資轉頭去買了個一億的遊艇這肯定不行對吧
合理，所以洗錢就是要同時解決這兩件事，消除痕跡，合理化收入。一會兒咱們會看到各種各樣的洗錢手法，它最終的目的就是為瞭解決這兩件事。來，咱們先從一些經典的簡單的手法聊起。我們要知道，在早期的時候，大部分的犯罪分子，比如說毒梟，他的這個髒錢實際上是以現金的形式出現的。所以最經典的洗錢的方法，就是去利用那些有大量現金交易的產業。
比如說開個餐館啊，開個洗衣店啊，或者再大點，開個賭場，開個金店這種。因為這些產業它本身每天就會有大量的合法的現金進進出出。那我其實非常容易就可以把這些髒錢給混進去。比如說你個洗衣店一天實際上賺一萬塊錢，你混進去五千變成一萬五，也很合理。監管機構其實很難去蹲在那數你每天有多少客戶，或者去一筆一筆查你那個打票。神不知鬼不覺這五千塊錢就洗乾淨了。
所以你看它其實同時解決了消除痕跡和合理化收入這兩個問題1920年代的時候美國確實有一個黑幫老大自己開了個洗衣店以這種方式去洗錢Money laundering這個詞也就這麼來的你看大家覺得很形象對吧開洗衣店又把錢給洗乾淨了一語雙關這個詞就這麼被流傳下來
所以在早期有很多那種黑幫的老大或者是大毒梟都會有自己合法的業務合法的生意你要是直接去洗髒錢可能很容易露出馬腳但是我要把它跟乾淨的錢給混在一起那就容易多了也隱蔽的多
這種手法它也有它的侷限性首先你得自己有個實體的業務比如說你有一家餐館你這餐館一天沒幾個人那你怎麼能合理化說我每天能掙十萬塊錢所以他就很依賴這個實體的業務量洗錢的效率他就很難上去你想哪個毒梟他也不可能每天在那非常努力的苦心經營他的洗衣店到時候邊毒品沒怎麼賣出去洗衣店這邊做起來了變成個實業家了那也挺高效的
所以後來隨著犯罪洗錢的量越來越大，監管也越來越嚴，這種手法你撐死了只能作為洗錢整個鏈條的入口之一。這些罪犯為了隔離風險，一般也不會自己親自持有，可能就是代持或者搞一些空殼公司什麼的。還有一種利用現金交易的方式，也非常經典，叫做賭場洗錢。
當然不是說你自己開個賭場而是非常簡單的就是去賭場因為賭場其實是一個非常容易去解釋那些莫名其妙收入來源的地方很容易去合理化這些髒款而且大部分賭場也可以接收大量的錢金很多人他就會帶著錢去賭場換成籌碼然後就象徵性的玩一想贏一點輸一點都無所謂再把這些籌碼換成錢或者支票他就洗乾淨了要之後有人問你這錢哪來的我就說昨天我去玩21點運氣爆棚一下賺了300萬
其實以前呢這種賭場洗錢的方式還是挺盛行的不過據我瞭解最近二三十年吧大型的賭場也已經越來越正規監管越來越嚴這種直接拿著現金去賭場的行為就已經無異於你直接拿現金去銀行了所以現在也是越來越少有呢也大多數都是一些比較小額的洗錢
接下來咱們要說的幾個洗錢的手法它其實是利用資產不同形式之間的轉換去極大程度的增加監管機構追蹤這個錢的難度首先一種就是靠藝術品去洗錢
你看藝術品一般的拍賣會它對買賣雙方的隱私保護其實都可以做的非常好同時很多都可以接受獻金那就很適合洗錢而且藝術品對吧你這畫是值多少錢可能是一萬也可能是一個億它的波動可以很大所以很多洗錢它其實是隱藏在那種大額的藝術品拍賣裡
墨西哥政府在2012年就推出了一個反洗錢法，裡面就嚴格限制了藝術品交易裡使用現金的量。結果這個法案一經實施，原本墨西哥還蒸蒸日上的藝術品交易市場直接要債，很多原來那種冉冉升起的藝術新星的作品，無人問津。咱是不是就是說，一個合理的推測，原來這個藝術品市場就是一個洗錢的渠道。
當然也不是說所有藝術品交易就都是洗錢只是說那裡邊確實很有可能隱藏著這個當前咱得嚴謹點嘿嘿不過你花那種鉅款把藝術品買過來給家裡放著或者拿來欣賞不是它的主要玩法畢竟大部分的犯罪分子他可能對藝術也不感興趣常見的手法是什麼我先低價買入比如說十萬塊錢我買這幅畫然後我去找一個專家他就給我鑑定一番說這畫畫真好它值一千萬然後
我這十萬塊錢的畫再以一千萬的價格賣給一個我自己的空殼公司左手倒右手看起來很合理就成功的把這九百九十萬的髒錢變成了一個藝術品投資的合法收入沒準還能立一個我是個什麼藝術界上大師的稱號是吧
或者很多人還會用藝術品去行賄一般你要行賄直接給人打個現金也不好花你要送個藝術品既有格調又不容易被發現之後想要變現也可以很隱秘據我所知這種藝術品行賄加上洗錢的方式在巴西就還挺常見
再比如說他還可以有些變種的玩法比如說犯罪分子他想去賄賂這個老王老王就可以拿出他女兒的一幅畫放到這個拍賣行去拍賣然後犯罪分子註冊一個公司過去看一下說這簡直是大師級別的畫呀大分期轉世對吧後現代藝術沒跑了一千萬拍這本聯喜前代賄賂一條龍就搞定了當然我們剛說什麼十萬一千萬都是為了舉例讓大家聽的更明白一點實際的操作他可能不會這麼極端差這麼大
除了藝術品還有一種資產是幾乎所有的洗錢所有罪犯都會涉及到的就是房地產
雖說房產它不像藝術品價格波動可以那麼大但是犯罪分子是一般真喜歡又可以享受又可以投資又可以洗錢藝術品不一定大家都能欣賞的來但豪宅誰不喜歡很多情況下房產就是犯罪分子洗錢的一個終點站比如咱最開始提到的新加坡洗錢案它光在新加坡就涉及到多達207處的房產這還可能只是他們全球洗錢的冰山一角據不完全統計這其中有兩人在迪拜有價值超過3100萬美元的房產
房地產在洗錢的過程中也可以有不同的作用最直接的它可以消費掉你的現金有一些國家它是接受你直接拿一大筊現金去買房子還不會對你進行收入和身份的調查就比如我們之前剛講過的禮拜
或者房地產還能幹什麼它可以作為一個你財富來源的證明就比如說你利用空殼公司裡的贓款買了房然後你把房子再賣掉這樣賣房得到的錢就變成了一部分合法的收入你這些錢再往銀行裡存的時候人家問你錢哪來的呀你就說我賣房子得的對吧合法合理大部分的銀行是不會再去追問你說那你當時買房的錢是怎麼來的呀人家不會這麼問的總之這些洗錢犯他們是非常熱愛房地產
你看這麼大量的洗錢都要經過房地產而且這些洗錢犯他們其實是不太在意那個房產的絕對價值多一點少一點對他可能沒那麼大影響他們是最願意去肆無忌憚的加價購買所以我跟你說這個其實也是推動像迪拜新加坡香港倫敦紐約這些地方房價的一個重要原因我們剛說是藝術品房產還有一個也是非常常用的資產轉換的方式就是黃金洗錢
黃金的好處是什麼面與運輸面與攜帶流動性也比藝術品房產好就是我非常容易買賣來我給你個實際的例子哈咱來看看一個摩洛哥的洗錢團夥他是怎麼幫助英國的毒販洗錢的首先在英國這個毒銷每次會把數十萬的現金就放在汽車的後備箱裡一般呢他會找一個公共場合比如說一個星巴克去跟這個洗錢的對接人A碰面倆人進去就會對眼神對暗號天王蓋蒂虎敖塔震和妖怪就是你了坐下
然後毒販就會偷偷地把這個車鑰匙給到追階人Ain the car之後A就會開著這個裝滿髒款的車開始他的洗錢之路這個A明面上是一個機場的清潔工有個不太起眼的角色他就會物理上把這個錢從英國帶到巴黎在巴黎給到一個街頭人B一個救護車司機
B呢就會把錢給到他哥哥C這個C他負責點鈔加留點鈔機他就會把這個錢全都清點一遍然後把它打包成一萬塊錢一捆一萬塊錢一捆全程都極其小心門窗緊閉還會特意把電視聲開的特別大來掩蓋這個點鈔的聲音之後呢這個B再去拿到這些已經點完鈔點成一捆一捆的錢給到兩個下面的中間人B和E這是兩個中年女子
D和E就會開著車把這些錢帶到比利時找到一個黑市的黃金商人F把這些錢換成黃金而且還有一些偽造的收據這樣你拿著黃金就不像拿著幾大箱現金那麼招搖了就算海關發現你有收據也不那麼可疑然後D和E就會帶著黃金從比利時飛到阿姆斯特丹再從阿姆斯特丹飛到迪拜
咱之前也聊到過迪拜是黃金之城他們就會在迪拜把這些黃金再換成乾淨的現金然後再把現金拿到銀行分批存起來拿到世界各地空殼公司的匿名賬戶裡去
你看看這一整套我這手都不夠用了整個流程非常的複雜非常的隱秘也非常的專業幾年中這個團夥就用這套方法洗錢了2.5億美元至於這裡邊為什麼要搞這麼多步買了賣換來換去又挪來挪去具體的原因老實講我也不是特別清楚八成是為了規避這些不同國家之間的一些監管規定但是底層的邏輯咱們其實是清楚的
就是利用現金的物理搬運，利用國境線的隔離，利用現金和黃金之間資產的形式轉換，來消除痕跡，給監管製造困難。那你說這麼隱密，這麼謹慎的手段，怎麼被發現了呢？我跟你說，確實，它這個鏈條越長，它裡面潛在的破綻也越多。當時是一個安勇的審計師，在查迪拜的一個珠寶巨頭叫Kaloti的賬的時候，就發現這公司怎麼每年花這麼多現金去買黃金，超過三噸的黃金。
怎麼有那麼多客戶需要現金而不是轉賬報警之後警察順藤摸瓜在2017年的時候就把整個洗錢的鏈條給揪出來27個人的團夥抓了25個但這個團夥的兩個老大至今都還沒被抓到你看咱剛才說了我可以把錢轉換成藝術品轉換成房地產黃金這種形式去洗錢類似其實還有很多形式比如說奢侈品鑽石甚至充值卡等等
最近幾年還很流行利用NFT咱也可以把它叫做元宇宙圈的藝術品這個資產形式它每一次轉換調查的難度都會指數級增加
罪犯肯定是想找那種可以匿名交易的盡量少留下痕跡的甚至他都要躲著攝像頭去參與這種資產形式之間的轉換接下來咱們來說說你怎麼能讓這個錢變得合理就好比說咱最開始說的那個小壞蛋他想合理化這一萬塊錢的收入他就可以跟他媽媽說這是我給同學補課的收入這就是一種合理化的方式這個合理化收入的玩法可以說是非常的五花八門甚至都可以說有點個性化了因為理論上任何你可以用匿名形式去進行的投資比如說你用贓款
買下來個諮詢公司買個貿易公司買個餐廳等等之後這些實體賺來的錢那就是乾淨的錢只不過一般這種以洗錢為目的的投資吧他都是非常的急功近利他也沒想把這實業做大做強他就是想把錢進去涮一遍所以這類洗錢為目的參與的經濟活動他一般有個非常顯著的特點就他不會以盈利為目的而是他想去盡量把現金流做高比如說你可以利用影視公司洗錢因為拍電影拍電視劇這種他這個錢又細又雜其實就非常適合偽裝
比如說犯罪分子他以公司A的名義投資拍個電影然後就找自己的公司B去搭一個場景然後給他炸掉實際上你炸這玩意總共可能就花了一百萬但我可以就說這個項目一共是五百萬反正都炸乾淨了也死無對證這個四百萬就直接洗乾淨當然我說爆炸這種可能確實是一個比較極端的形式了
但你整個在拍攝過程當中你隨便哪塊都可以去虛開發票或者可以造假對吧或者你就拍個電影之後上映的時候你可以包場去做票房把票房都做的報告那這個票房收入就相當於是洗白這是影視公司再比如說還可以通過足球隊洗錢
你比如說俄羅斯有商人叫土耳斯基科夫他在2014年的時候就收購了一家葡萄牙的已經陷入到財務危機的俱樂部叫萊裡亞然後這個足球隊就成了俄羅斯黑手黨洗錢網當中非常重要的一環他們就會通過球員轉匯呀電視轉播權交易呀或者博彩的方式去洗錢
結果2016年的時候葡萄牙警方發起了所謂的俄羅斯套娃行動明兒還挺有意思的就把這個足球隊突擊搜查抓到了三個俄羅斯黑手黨的成員你知道葡萄牙警方他是怎麼懷疑上這個足球隊的嗎其實他們從洗錢的角度手法都是非常謹慎的但是就有人發現你說你一個快破產的俱樂部它的老闆每天的生活怎麼這麼極致的奢華然後還這麼大手筆的去買賣球員轉匯關鍵是買了還不知道他們上場是吧這也太奇怪了就有了這麼一個俄羅斯套娃行動
再還有一種比較常見的方式叫做貿易洗錢它甚至都有它自己的縮寫叫做TBMLTrade Based Money Laundering貿易洗錢它為什麼常見呢一是貿易的量可以很大就是你資金的量可以很大同時海關對於這個貨物它其實也很難去嗨餓那麼去清點檢查同時它還有一個好處就是可以讓資金跨境流動方法其實也不複雜比如說你可以不開發票比如說我讓國外寄給我
一噸木材它價值可能就一萬塊錢但我可以說這是上等的木頭我可以花一千萬買它你說海關也不知道這個木頭是好是壞呀那就人說一千萬就一千萬吧這樣我這一千萬就打出鏡了也很合理或者你也可以反過來
比如說我進口了一批上等的木材實際上價值一千萬但我就打一萬塊錢出去然後這些木材我在國內賣掉比如賣一千萬那這一千萬就變成了合法的收入當然咱們剛說這個例子裡頭跟你進行貿易的這個對甲肯定也是你的犯罪同夥而且我們舉的例子數字也比較極端它肯定不可能是一萬和一千萬差這麼多現實當中比如說五十萬開一百萬的發票這種還是更真實一些
很多國家不是有跨境的資本管制嗎所以就會出現很多專門針對跨境交易的洗錢手法有一招還挺陰險的叫鏡像交易2011年到2015年期間一個俄羅斯的經紀人又是俄羅斯他叫沃爾科夫
他會經常去聯繫德意志銀行的交易部幫他俄羅斯公司的賬戶用盧布去買一個俄羅斯藍籌股的股票這股票是什麼不重要但他每次都會大概買價值一千萬美元左右的這個股票同時呢沃爾科夫又會讓這個交易員幫他在一個境外的賬戶比如說註冊在維京群島的賬戶賣出同樣數量的股票把它賣成美元或者歐元
因為這兩筆交易是同時進行的所以這個價格幾乎是一樣的你看對沃爾科夫來講我國內買股票海外賣股票其實抵銷了但是我國內花的是盧布海外賣出來是美元
德意志銀行在中間順便轉了一些手續費這種交易持續了4年之久到2015年被發現的時候已經進行了超過100億美元的轉賬沃爾科夫的經濟公司成了一個俄羅斯地下的轉賬機構幫很多的俄羅斯富豪或者是寡頭把資產轉移到海外後來德意志銀行也是被罰慘了被英國的金融監管局罰了1.63億英鎊美國的金融服務部又罰了他4.25億美元
你看這種手法其實說白了它就是把資金換成某種資產然後在境外給賣出去相當於完成了一次跨境換匯又不用受到各種監管的限制其實你不光可以利用股票了就之前新華網就報導過說有一些犯罪分子他會利用遊戲幣或者遊戲點卡來進行類似的洗錢操作去跨過大陸的人民幣外匯管制累計的洗錢金額將近400億人民幣
好 咱們剛才說了那麼多合理化收入 資產隔離的洗錢手法其實我有意隱藏了一種最最常用也可以說是當代洗錢手法當中核心中的核心就是利用空核公司洗錢
什麼叫空殼公司？簡單來說就是沒什麼實際業務的公司一般這些犯罪分子他就會匿名在避稅天堂比如我們之前講的北京群島百慕大開曼群島巴拿馬等等註冊大量的公司然後再以這些空殼公司的名義去銀行大量的匿名開戶我跟你說在這些地方註冊公司可以說是非常的容易你就在網上兩三分鐘點一點他也不需要什麼個人信息就註冊成功了企業的負責人你當地顧一個就行有代理幫你搞這個事出事呢基本也不會查到你頭上
銀行開戶可能稍微麻煩一點，你得找個代理人，或者成立個信託公司，讓這個受託人幫你去開戶。但總之吧，這個空殼公司的設立和銀行的開戶都是非常容易的，也不需要什麼個人信息。犯罪份子他就會搞一大批註冊在世界各地的空殼公司和這些銀行賬戶。這就成了他們資產網絡的一個基本盤，也可以說是他的一個洗錢網。他們要進行的大部分的經濟活動，
基本都是要以這些公司這些銀行賬戶為關鍵節點比如說咱看一個1990年代墨西哥的黑幫他利用空殼公司洗錢非常常見的套路
首先我把大量的信心贓款在盧森堡以一個海外空殼公司A的名義存成定期的大額存單然後用這個大額存單作為擔保以一家直布羅陀公司B的名義去巴黎貸款這又加了一層了最後這個公司B再把錢轉到毒販控制的一個巴達馬的空殼公司C的名下你看亂吧
這樣一來這監管機構如果想調查這個毒販他得先搞清楚巴拿馬他有哪一些空殼公司巴拿馬就有一道銀行保密法然後你還得過巴黎那關就算你足夠仔細查到了底你還得再過盧森堡那關這髒款在這個網絡裡頭打來打去打個幾圈就很難追回來了即使能追回來可能也所剩無幾
說到這我覺得可能很多朋友就會有疑問既然那麼多犯罪分子在利用這些空殼公司去隱藏信息進行一些非法操作那為什麼要有這些空殼公司存在呢？我給它禁了不行嗎？因為這個空殼公司它其實在合法經營裡用處也是非常廣的比如說公司的管理架構上我想擱幾個一起合夥控股一個公司那我就可以一起成立一個空殼公司去控股
或者稅務規劃上我可以不同國家成立不同的空殼公司交叉控股這個咱們其實之前講碧水天堂那期視頻裡頭有詳細的聊過總之呢空殼公司它對當代的商業來說可以說是必不可少的雖說這些罪犯在利用空殼公司去進行一些控制但它其實問題並不是出在空殼公司本身的機制上就好比說這些罪犯它也都在用賬戶之間轉賬呢你不能說給大家所有轉賬都給禁了對吧
問題還是出在一些國家和地區它對空殼公司的監管上尤其是那些避稅天堂那些群島這個監管要我說確實非常不到位打著保護隱私的名義妨礙了反洗錢的調查來吸引各個海外大量的資金和大量的業務不過2017年之後他們也迫於像美國、歐盟反洗錢的壓力開始去一點一點也加強自己反洗錢的監管力度不過總的來說就是你推他一下他就往前挪半步不情不願的反正大概是這麼個情況
你發現沒有啊，這一部裡邊它其實非常主要的一個特點，就是它利用了國家和國家之間監管規則的不同。如果你要這些所有的空殼公司都放在一個國家裡頭，政府非常容易就夠得著。但是一旦涉及到跨國，一下就變得非常困難。其實這些監管部門它要是想查，它也是可以挖下去的。但是這一層一層的查是有非常大的人力成本和時間成本。洗錢者跟監管者，它本質上就是一個貓鼠遊戲。貓鼠就想盡可能地比貓跑得快一點，跑得遠一點，再疊一層buff。
據我所知，國內其實是一種很常見的疊buff的方式，就是犯罪分子他會先在國內建立好多個銀行帳戶。雖然這些帳戶理論上你是需要實名認證的，但是他可以盜用信息。即使這些被盜用信息身份的本人，他可能都不知道自己名下居然開了這些帳戶。所以大家要是有的時候比如手機啊郵箱啊，收到什麼讓你確認開戶確認的，你就小心了，這有可能就是你的身份信息被盜用了。
然後這些詐騙犯贓款一旦到賬比如說北京某個老大爺被電話詐騙了30萬轉出去了這筆錢先是會在這犯罪分子這麼多個不是他自己名下的賬戶裡轉好幾輪這就是分層了先爭取到一些時間然後就會轉移到境外比如說巴拿馬的一個銀行賬戶裡去境外再分層你這就很難找回來了就算這個老大爺立刻報警了咱就實際一點你可能讓警察叔叔打電話給巴拿馬政府Can you help me查一查這30萬元這不太可能吧
也就是像什麼比如恐怖組織、大毒梟或者是一些大貪汙犯才會驚動各個國家聯合來一起調查這個事件。其實你要是看教科書裡，它會告訴你洗錢分三步。首先是把冰箱門打開。不不不。首先叫安置 placement。就是讓錢進入到金融系統。然後叫分層 layering。
就是讓錢去進行多次的轉移，這樣追查起來非常困難。第三步在整合integration。
把錢合法化的弄到自己的賬戶或者把它花出去這個為什麼我沒給大家特別詳細的介紹因為我在研究的時候發現那些實際的案例很難那麼一一對應到這三步上而且這幾個詞說實話聽著就挺晦澀的我要是老跟你說說這個是安置這個是安置和分層這個是整合和分層我估計對吧你都暈了所以這三步我們就是了解你知道一下就好我覺得更好理解的還是剛才我總結的那兩個底層的原則消除終結和合理化收入
而我們剛才說的空殼公司之間的來回轉賬其實就是它消除蹤跡的一個非常好的方法也是對應著剛剛我們說那三步法裡頭的第二步分層的一個主要手段
類似這種通過金融轉賬分層洗錢其實還有一些變種的形式。這些洗錢犯除了可以盜用你的身份或者是偷偷登錄，他甚至可以騙你在不知情的情況下協助他洗錢。這樣監管機構想偵查難度就更大了。怎麼講呢？比如說你是一個普普通通的好人，洗錢犯會想辦法讓這個錢在你的賬戶過一遍。你先打給他，過一段時間他再打給你，讓你成為了洗錢過程當中分層的一個點。
當然大家也不傻呀，誰閒得沒事要配合洗錢呢？所以洗錢飯一般會把它包裝成一個充值的形式。比如說你要想充值，你就把錢先打給他，要麼充個遊戲幣呀，要麼充個電話費呀這種。他收到錢之後過一段時間，會把這個錢打到你的電話帳戶或者遊戲那個帳戶裡頭去。通常情況下，他還會再搞一些甜頭去吸引更多人來參加，就比如說充話費。
充80得100,這就很誘人了，就會有很多人上購。你點開那個充值的鏈接，充了80,你以為是充到運營商平臺了，但實際上這個錢是轉給了一個洗錢的中介。這個洗錢中介會匹配到另一段，比如說詐騙來的錢，或者是一些非法賭博平臺充值的錢，再把這一百打到你的賬上，就形成了一個閉環，你就不知不覺成為了一個洗錢的幫兇。
而因為要匹配到這邊的贓款它需要一些時間所以這種一般都叫做所謂的慢充一兩天才能到賬中介這明面上可能會跟你說哎呀這得排隊呀募契現在擁堵正忙實際上背面可能在那忙著坑蒙拐騙這個就是一個例子洗錢中介他可能會偽裝成各種充值的形式來誘騙你所以大家可千萬別貪那種小便宜不然哪天你正好被封或者警察叔叔上門找你的時候別怪我沒提醒你
你看啊，空殼公司轉賬，它其實是利用國境線作為屏障，利用隱私保護來分層，擦出痕跡。這個慢充洗錢呢，它是利用一個在不認識的人的帳戶裡走一圈，分層擦出痕跡。而分層它更高階一點的模式是什麼？就是連人都不一樣了。你把錢打給A,但是B打給你。實際上這個A跟B是一夥的，但表面上它倆可能什麼關係都沒有。神不知鬼不覺把錢給洗了。這套玩法就是地下錢莊。
地下錢莊就是一個隱藏的地下銀行系統。有一大幫個人公司的賬戶，表面看上去沒什麼關係，但實際上他們是一個利益共同體。你可想而知，這種地下錢莊對監管機構來講是非常棘手的。它利用的是人與人之間那種虛無縹緲的信任。所以你沒法從客觀的一些數據、轉賬信息裡去掘紮出一些端倪。
當然現在監管機構其實也在不斷去升級自己的監測技術比如說新加坡就應用了一種新的基於AI的探測手段盡可能的把各種支付系統連網然後去交叉檢查發現一些可疑的行為比如說你這個設備怎麼一下登錄了幾千個帳戶或者這麼多設備這麼多帳戶怎麼同時連了一個Wi-Fi這兩個帳戶它倆怎麼總是進行反向交易等等吧從這些錯綜複雜的信息當中去找到規律
你看啊，咱們今天說了這麼多種洗錢的方式。咱再來看看最開始我們說的那個新加坡最大的洗錢案。你可能就會覺得，不過如此。
這些犯罪分子呢，首先他們會把髒款在全球各個空殼公司之間打來打去，分層。然後你知道他是怎麼繞過新加坡銀行監管的審核嗎？說起來特別low,就是造假證。他們就自己偽造，批圖，批了一個國內某大銀行的對賬單作為自己的財富證明。還有偽造賣房的證明，就說我這錢是賣房來的。甚至還批自己在企業高管的就職證明等等。這就完了，就通過了。
其實造假證也屬於洗錢的一個慣用伎倆了但我覺得確實有點對吧這太簡單了所以我剛講那些手法的時候壓根就沒說它之後呢他們再把這些資產轉移到新加坡轉移到迪拜轉移到英國購買上百套的房產買豪車遊艇加密貨幣等等但我跟你說他們露馬腳也是因為這個造假證
2021──．．．．．．
最終被捕的這10個人，被判13-17個月監禁，沒收了95%-100%的財產。基本上都在今年的5月-7月份，因為表現良好，提前被假釋出獄，並且被新加坡永久驅逐出境。他們在新加坡被判的刑期，只是針對他們在新加坡洗錢的部分，不包括他們詐騙、非法賭博那些。而那些沒收的資產，都通過拍賣等的渠道出售，進入到了新加坡政府的基金裡。
單就這個案子來說，稍微狹隘一點的說，新加坡政府倒是挺賺的，沒收了幾十億美元。但實際上，這麼大的洗錢案，對新加坡造成的生育成本其實是不可估量的。所以新加坡也迅速加強了對銀行、對房地產的審查，修改了新加坡的《反貪汙反洗錢法案》，尤其加強了對海外富豪的資產審查。搞得現在很多富豪想把資產轉移到新加坡，或者在新加坡開家族辦公室，變得非常的麻煩。
這就導致了一個很有意思的現象你知道是什麼嗎就這一兩年你會發現在香港成立家族辦公室變得非常火熱甚至有一些富豪會顯得把資產從新加坡轉移到香港這也讓香港來了這麼一大波資本流入你看挺有意思的吧這都是一些牽一髮而共全身的博弈
注意啊我不是說這些富豪把錢轉到香港或者選擇去香港就說明他這些錢是髒錢我不是這個意思我其實也問了一些在新加坡香港從事私人財富管理的這種財富管理經理這些富豪他們大部分情況下就是嫌麻煩我本來選擇新加坡選擇香港就是想讓這個資本自由通暢的流動希望它效率高一點快一點現在新加坡加了這麼一堆條條框框的要查這查那證明這證明那的所以有些人就會因為嫌這個麻煩選擇了香港
所以這從側面其實也說明瞭為什麼那些避稅天堂會那麼不配合這些全球反洗錢的推進。好傢伙你看咱聊著洗錢又跑到全球博弈上去了。這個全球的反洗錢系統尤其是在金融發達的地區我感覺它有點像一個氣球。
看起來好像密不透風很密閉很完美但實際上它有可能一捅就破你知道反洗錢的第一原則叫什麼嗎叫做瞭解你的客戶Know your customer也叫KYC你要是在銀行工作的朋友尤其是一些歐美的銀行肯定對KYC這個詞特別熟你要瞭解你的客戶怎麼瞭解呢不知道反正你就是要瞭解瞭解他的業務瞭解他的意圖
這個其實也合理因為洗錢的手法現在可以說是日新月異銀行的監管規則呢它很難趕上洗錢進化的速度只能依靠第一線的客戶經理去進行主觀的判斷這就有很多漏洞了對吧要不然你那麼大一個洗錢案30億美元呀怎麼可能幾個假證差點就矇混過關了包括我們剛剛說的那個鏡像交易這裡面很重要的一個原因就是這個德意志銀行的交易員他知情不報才讓這些洗錢犯可以兩邊跨國買賣就是看起來這麼森嚴的一個銀行監管它其實靠的就是第一線的客戶經理
所以一些銀行的合規部門想推進一些反洗錢審查的時候
客戶經理第一個跳起來就不高興了你讓這麼搞你讓客戶走這麼多流程咱以後我跟你說可就沒客戶了所以有的時候會發生什麼情況呢這些客戶經理他有可能就不執行或者執行的很鬆因為這裡頭很多東西很主觀還有可能跟著客戶一起去糊弄監管所以你看就是利益衝突這兒我們就不往深聊了
為什麼反洗錢進展的這麼不順利洗錢現在在全球這麼猖獗就是因為它其實是一個巨大的博弈場這裡頭有洗錢者和監管者的博弈同時還有國家和國家之間它的博弈再到一個國家內部它可能還有監管和銀行之間的博弈它其實是非常微妙的最後的最後我再強調一下洗錢是犯法洗錢是犯罪不能洗錢不能洗錢不能洗錢
我給你講點早事。那咱今天就廢話少說，帶大家一口氣瞭解一下，洗錢是怎麼回事。有點，腿部有點過。